i'm a bit afraid to ask after what we've
just talked about but what is your
creative process do you have one
right
um
because i'm sure you have like the
answer prepared for like when you get
asked that on a panel and like i i hear
you ask uh ask that question on the
panel and i'm just like that that is not
like the kevin
i know so uh yeah um
so it's kind of weird because um because
i don't like
i haven't
he's probably he's buffering he's
probably
buffering
like that
whatever it's called a dlr
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
um
it comes from like it comes from many
places
i can't make that sound good so i'm just
going to meme it but um
so
let's say for example one one way is
that i've um
i've like woken up in the middle of the
night i had like some sort of [ __ ]
weird fever dream but then i'm working
up with like some sort of melody in my
head yeah i'll write it down as like
almost like a musical morse code on like
evernote because i got like evernote and
a lot of people yeah i'll do like a
little memories like b dash dash is like
b for two beats sorry like a temper
maybe like uh like a like
tempo you wake up thinking about
melodies some only like sometimes but
then the problem is i'll like write it
down be like oh that's [ __ ] good i'm
gonna go back to sleep now i'm gonna
wake up nice and early after i've had a
nice rest and you know just like get get
to work and i wake up and like oh
it means like nothing for me
so i have to like reinterpret what i
like wrote some momentum
because i used to do that as well
and but now now
but now when i do it yeah i just sing
into my phone so the next morning i wake
up and i'm just like it's just like
audio of me just like
it's like really quietly like three in
the morning aki must think i'm [ __ ]
psychotic
because they're singing to myself at
three in the morning yeah i mean but it
helps yeah
i mean
another way that i like start a piece of
music would be like let's just try and
like find a cool sound or a cool like
right right right so yeah whether it be
like
one of the uh sort of uh one of the uh
therapy synthesizers that i decided to
try
which synthesizer should i use today
yeah he's loading up loading up logic
pro and just being like okay let's let's
[ __ ] around and just see what happens
so
yeah it's just like well most of it's
[ __ ] but then eventually you get
something that's like okay it's not
too [ __ ] that i couldn't come back and
like refine it later
might be a little bit of a riff or
something sometimes like that but so
like um
let's take uh let's take um
the rising of the shield here main theme
mm-hmm start it's just like sad piano
boom
that's like sad piano yeah yeah yeah
yeah but then you have um this this
violin coming coming and going bit a bit
a bit a bit a bit a bit yeah yeah
it rises up yeah
um
that
what's the melody version of that i
guess
i'm sorry people i'm very good
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
yeah yeah sorry i'm too sorry i didn't
come prepared
so i would start with that and try and
work around that right like i guess you
could think of it as like you know you
create like one little line and then
you're creating another line that kind
of connects to that and so it kind of
slowly becomes like a sort of a bit more
of a complicated kind of beast comes
like patchwork type of thing right yeah
and like you kind of like go back to
like kind of fill in and refine
so like maybe i'll have like a structure
or something i'll have like you know
most of a structure or something
um to work with and then i'll just kind
of sit back and be like okay what sucks
what needs to be changed and just kind
of refined almost like um something like
uh is it trench fishing
what's that
it's it's weird it's where like they are
yeah it's like it's like a net and they
that was the loudest like five seconds
of silence ever on the show that was
like that was the loudest science i've
ever heard
i was trying to process it was like i
think i thought yeah i was trying to say
dredge but then i thought i'd like the
mariana trench
nightmare that is my head
yeah dredge fishing right like you think
of that as like but you're just like
going through you're listening yeah yeah
yeah i don't know actually
yeah then you're just kind of refining
refining refining it until
you kind of can't find any more like
flaws so to speak right right right or
you run out of time right yeah do you
kind of like do you kind of like show
those like unfinished or like you know
combed through pieces to like other
people to get like a second opinion or
do you kind of just like all the time
there's like a few
kind of like kind of core people where
i'll be like hey so yes yeah right yeah
just be honest yeah let's just tell me
that yeah tell me what's the track in
your row like and you're just like this
one's the banger this one's a [ __ ]
bang and i can't wait to hear this this
this this is the one that will explode
my career
i don't think like that i don't think
like that um what what i normally like
more what i gravitate more in terms of
like being confident about a track is
kind of the process of it yeah um here's
an example that i can't tell you like
now but like last night but um like
let's let's take like maiden abyss uh
season one for example right um
there's a track that i mentioned earlier
called swings and roundabouts and it
involves a really cool sort of arpeggio
style playing a playing technique um
called arpeggiation on a violin so
normally when you play violin and i'm
sorry any violence out there about to
[ __ ] hate me because i'm not i'm
gonna explain what a violin does like as
a flawless and it's gonna suck but um if
you think of it because normally you see
a violin they play one or two strings at
the time and then they normally change
their fingers like that um
one of the techniques that i really
enjoyed was where they put fingers in
all four strings and then just kind of
go up and down um on on all four strings
right right right right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right right right right always make like
a chord
well if you do like that doesn't do much
we go one two three four back one two
three four buttons
so it's like this kind of cool kind of
chord sort of thing and and you can play
it quite they play it very very fast
because yeah [ __ ] good musicians yeah
yeah but then you can change that all
the time so you know you always like
and you can kind of change your chords
all the time and you can make like this
really cool like because it's a very
shimmery sort of texture but um i did
that on one violin and then i had
in in the best season one we had three
violins three viola two chelly and one
bass and they were all of them playing
like solo parts so it's like nine songs
right right and they're all playing
these different chords like arpeggiated
chords together and it's sort of making
this bit of this sort of cacophony of
like sounds and stuff yeah like doing
those sorts of things makes me feel good
about that track it's like oh i got to
explore this kind of crazy thing
yeah exactly it's like oh i got to like
kind of explore that and it didn't
[ __ ] face it
and it sounds good yeah yeah that was
great yeah and that and i like them i
like the noise yeah this is so alien to
me that you're explaining all this stuff
and it literally just sounds like
another world like it doesn't sound like
a
thing that i can even comprehend but i
appreciate it because you know i i know
you're making sense yeah it's just like
to me such engineering and math brain
yeah the way i approach everything and
like it's very like okay i just do it i
do there's nothing that's like just a
gut feeling there's no experimentation
yeah yeah you know
i mean i mean there needs to be a part
of that in in in this process
because experience means that you can
execute these ideas
i've i've had like crazy [ __ ] ideas i
have no idea how to do and i still don't
yeah i was gonna i was gonna ask well
you said something earlier and i was
like how do you convi see like you said
mentioned that you're in like a a chapel
or something and you're recording like
yeah orchestra or something right
how do you go like hey hey hey
higher-ups um i have this idea yeah i'd
like to rent out a church somewhere in
austria could we ship uh and get a bunch
of violinists and all the people yeah um
yeah it might it might work out let's
just see how it right by the way it's a
hundred thousand dollars yeah
the uh the my part is definitely not
something that i translate yeah
you'll like it it's definitely it's
definitely gonna work i mean like first
like first off thankfully there's trust
so like that right right
yeah a little bit of trust but um
so obviously like when you when you
start a project you give it a budget
yeah and uh you know the budget you know
sometimes you can like kind of stretch
it a little bit and you know you can do
something a little bit of black magic
just to get some deals it's budget like
this might sound stupid there's budget
and then you get your pay separate right
that's like completely yeah yeah yeah
there's make it all unknown
no there's a composer's fee and then
there's
something production fingerprints
right
um
so uh
when we were able to kind of like
explore this idea of using made in best
an example like yeah we're trying to
explore this like this massive studio uh
called the synchron stage in vienna
which i think it fits like 135 musicians
it's a massive room yeah like i'm pretty
sure it's like a football field if not
slightly more like i understand that
battery yeah
there we go
like it's got a really unique sound
profile and so you can stick like a
really small amount of musicians in
there and it will sound [ __ ] huge
because they put all these microphones
around you get all these ambient mic
friends they stick like 30 feet up in
the air and stuff and you have they're
called out triggers and you've got like
everything man you've got all this sound
to play with is that not just like a
nightmare to have to go through all
those different like
angles of sounds
setting up like four mics for this
[ __ ] yeah
you have absolute permission like slit
my throat i don't actually utilize the
space like that like nuts yeah yeah yeah
yeah but no like so the space is
phenomenal and then we get a small
amount of musicians because like we
decided like okay small amount of
characters in the film
in the show a small amount of musicians
to kind of like mimic that kind of
yeah yeah and so just having like yeah
like three solid violins three solo
viola three uh two solos each other one
solo bass but then they're all kind of
doing their own thing but because the
space is so good and so clean you can
have all these voices like really not if
you orchestrate correctly right you can
uh so it's like if you balance your
textures correctly and all that sort of
[ __ ] yeah um you can have like a really
rich sound with a small amount of people
and yeah you sound phenomenal right
it's beautiful it's really fun
performing magic yeah yeah yeah this
means you just said like so many words
that i'm like
i'm like damn man say that again
i mean because sometimes like i
appreciate it
i mean sometimes like just the basic
stuff like even just doing the bass like
but it is like kind of let's call it
simple like refined simple right sort of
ideas is really really fun uh one of the
other tracks that's that's in the best
season one called um recapitulation um
something in recapitulation sorry but
you probably remember my own tracks
um but it just involves the nine strings
just playing like playing just notes
all they're doing is changing the
duration of the bow hand in order to get
shorter or longer uh shorter or longer
notes
[Laughter]
they have like three different levels of
length of nose but it's the same note
it's the same note i mean we change up
the chord sometimes but it is quite
minimalistic right
right uh but um
so basically
if you change the texture in that room
the um because you have something called
um
uh oh christ i should probably remember
the damn thing from um
what's called
um it's like early reflections earlier
reflections i think it's called early
reflections okay right right right the
early reflections of the sound so like
the sound that's kind of like because
sounds flying everywhere in the room
right yeah
sound goes everywhere and obviously it
bounces off certain certain points and
then comes back to the microphone yeah
those early reflections early
reflections
in that room are really really cool
right and they have a lot of character
because it's almost like an echo effect
effect
and so for example if i recorded your
voice in there but i didn't use like the
mic that's in front of you but i use the
mics that caught like the first
reflections of you just behind you or in
front of you or something like that
right it would almost sound like there's
like 10 of you right right really cool
of course it's quite unique to that i
mean because it's kind of like spread
out and bounced around a little bit
right yeah because of the quality of the
quality of the wood in the room and
stuff yeah things change
so it is it is like a really good room
so is this like is this place like
famous because i can't imagine okay
you're gonna record a soundtrack you
want like a certain sound profile for
like made in the best like because this
place seems like it was tailor-made for
a series like maiden abyss and caverns
and wide open spaces yeah how would you
like go about finding the perfect
recording spot or the perfect space the
correct recording spot yeah yeah the
correct yeah for this it was that one um
i think for well because rising of the
shield hero we recorded in boston with a
rock orchestra and they specified in
rock orchestra so the players did live
performances at the time uh with with a
full live band i think they did some fun
fantasy stuff among other square enix
projects among other things as well
right so they like kind of specialized
in that kind of quite cool kind of
attitude orchestra with rock which which
is what we wanted to achieve here right
tower of god um
obviously i mean it's it's in the name
as well it has like a slightly biblical
sort of
sensibility about it and um we found
this hall in the czech republic called
the dvorak hall
so it's this beautiful old hall it was
built i think in the name of the borjak
so he's like a a very very very um
famous um composer
romantic
uh
right yeah late romantic music but um
so this hall was designed either for him
or by him or around him so sorry about
not being specific about it but it is a
beautiful concert hall it is it is
ancient it is it has this beautiful lush
sort of like reverb tail and stuff it is
[ __ ] pretty to like listen to
and it's a performance tool but they
also do recording there yeah and uh
which so we recorded string orchestra
there for shower of code because it had
this sort of almost um cathedral-esque
sort of sensibility
which worked great for certain aspects
of the tarragon soundtrack right that's
right concept right right
so this this one haul
it was
they had a very specific sound that say
and you're a normal cathedral wouldn't
i'm sure a normal cathedral would but
that's when practicality comes into it
so i make sure at the end of the day
that
um you know you could again you gotta
you gotta fit within certain budgets and
stuff like that yeah yeah yeah yeah i
mean that's that's part of like the
business skills part of it which yeah
right so imagine you have these these
grandiose ideas and this this concept
that you have yeah and there's a guy
there that is like i am here to scale
you back down
so you're pushing the envelope a little
bit aren't you like it's like i want to
record on the moon
because it's a space opera
like you know yeah
no there's no sound respect
we're getting real experimental we're
gonna we're gonna build a cathedral in
space yeah
apparently apparently a dying black hole
or like a black hole is like the loudest
sound ever but you can't hear it yeah
yeah i believe hopefully probably yeah
yeah yeah the moon would be nice but i
don't think i'm gonna
you're not gonna make a whole lot of
progress yeah no no i think tell us the
fact about the dying black hole being
the the loudest thing i think they did
manage to record it oh no yeah it's like
i think it is it must be the loudest
sound because it's it's a black hole
consuming stars but yeah they managed to
record the sound of it i think recently
and it's like just this eerie [ __ ]
yeah it's
it's adam's being crushed into nothing
yeah
right right right anyway yeah
interesting
[Laughter]
second loudest is a modern warfare 2
lobby
exactly